* Ein Hahn kräht,
eine Ziege meckert. *
Schon als Kind träumten sie davon,
später einmal Tierarzt zu werden.
Nach einem fünfjährigen Studium
starten sie mit Elan ins Berufsleben.
Aber dann kommt der Alltag.
Der bereitet viel Freude,
aber auch viele Schwierigkeiten.
Es gibt viele Überraschungen.
Wir haben drei junge Tierärztinnen
begleitet.
Alix spezialisiert sich im Moment
im Notfall des Tierspitals in Bern
in der Spitzentechnologie.
Mit ihrem Team betreut sie
die kritischen Fälle,
die täglich eingeliefert werden.
In Broye/VD steht Florence
zwischen Rindern und Pferden.
Der Druck in der Bauernwelt
ist gross.
Aber Florence behält ihre Ruhe
und ihre gute Laue.
Nach ihrer Zeit
mit Kühen und Schafen im Jura
spezialisiert sich Eléonore
auf Kleintiere in Estavayer-le-Lac.
Sie hat viel
mit den Besitzern zu tun,
die extrem an ihren Tieren hängen.
Das sind sie -
unsere jungen Tierärztinnen.
Auf diesem weitläufigen Betrieb
im Freiburgischen
produziert Thierry Milch
für die Produktion von Gruyère-Käse.
Jährlich ca. 730 t.
Eine seiner trächtigen Kühe
gefällt ihm heute Morgen nicht gut.
Komm, hopp!
Sania sollte kalbern,
aber es passiert nichts.
Auch ihr Verhalten ist nicht normal.
Der Kuh geht es gar nicht gut.
Sie hebt ständig den Schwanz.
Sie war die ganze Zeit unruhig.
Liegt ab, steht auf.
Sania ist vier
und zum zweiten Mal trächtig.
Vom Charakter her ist sie ruhig,
aber Thierry spürt,
dass etwas nicht stimmt.
Die Kuh beklagt sich praktisch nie.
Aber wenn man sieht,
dass es ihr nicht wohl ist,
kann man davon ausgehen,
dass sie Schmerzen hat.
Thierry ist es wichtig,
dass es den Kühen gut geht.
Darum hat er die Tierärztin gerufen.
Eléonore kommt
mit ihrer Assistentin Lilly.
Sie überlässt die Kleintiere
den anderen
und steigt wieder in die Stiefel.
Salut.
- Hallo, Thierry. Wie geht's?
Ja, und dir?
- Merci.
Darf ich?
- Also, gehen wir.
Thierry ist ein erfahrener Züchter.
Er vermutet, dass die Schmerzen von
einer Gebärmutterverdrehung kommen.
Bei einer Gebärmutterverdrehung
passiert Folgendes:
Die Gebärmutter mit dem Kälbchen
dreht sich in der Längsachse
um sich selbst.
Wenn es verdreht ist, öffnet sich
der Gebärmutterhals nicht
und das Kälbchen kann nicht raus.
Das passiert normalerweise,
wenn die Kühe unruhig sind
und sich ständig hinlegen
und wieder aufstehen.
Die Diagnose stimmt.
Es ist, wie von Thierry vermutet.
Greift man nicht ein,
sterben beide daran:
die Mutter
und das ungeborene Kälbchen.
Eléonore muss die Gebärmutter drehen.
Sie muss herausfinden,
in welche Richtung sie drehen muss,
damit es nicht schlimmer wird.
Das ist das Schwierigste am Ganzen.
Nach links.
Es ist ein ausgewrungener Lumpen.
Man muss mit der Hand
konzentriert der Falte entlang.
Beim Rausziehen
muss man darauf achten,
wie man die Hand gedreht hat.
Das Beste ist sicher, noch einmal
zu kontrollieren. Zwei-, dreimal.
Sie lacht zwar,
aber es ist überhaupt nicht einfach.
Nein, es ist links. Okay.
Auf drei. Es ist in bisschen ...
Aber es ist gut. Okay.
Ist sie nicht zu stark verdreht,
können wir sie mit der Hand drehen.
Das braucht viel Kraft
und Erfahrung.
Und wenn die Kraft fehlt,
braucht es gute Ideen.
Ich wälze sie. Ich habe
zu wenig Kraft, um sie zu drehen.
Wir legen die Kuh dorthin,
der Länge nach.
Dann drehen wir sie.
Ist der Lehrling da?
Thierry staunt.
Noch nie sagte ihm jemand, dass er
seine Kuh am Boden herumwälzen muss.
Als hätte Elénore
nicht genug mit einem Notfall,
klingelt auch noch das Telefon.
Hallo?
Nicolas, hörst du mich?
Ein weiterer Bauer hat Probleme
mit einer kalbernden Kuh.
Den Schwanz spürst du nicht?
Es sitzt nicht komplett.
Geh mit der Hand dem Bein entlang.
Spürst du dort ein Gelenk?
Einen Unterschenkel?
Es ist nicht einfach, sich die
Situation am Telefon vorzustellen.
Okay, d.h., es kommt rückwärts raus.
Man muss es rausziehen.
Wenn nicht, stirbt es.
Ich wälze die Kuh mit der Gebär-
mutterverdrehung über den Rücken
und komme dann zu dir.
Also, gut.
Wenn du denkst, es sei zu gross, um
es herausziehen, wartest auf mich.
Es ist sicherer.
Ist gut? Bis gleich.
Viel Zeit hat Eléonore also nicht.
Aber ein 600 kg schweres Tier
am Boden herumwälzen,
das ist keine leichte Sache.
Das gebe ich dir wieder.
Das Seil muss auf die andere Seite
und dann wieder unten durch.
Dann anziehen.- Durchziehen?
- Ja, übers Kreuz.
Einer Kuh
kann man nicht einfach sagen:
"Leg dich hin,
damit ich dich drehen kann."
Sie würde mich
mit grossen Augen anschauen.
Deshalb muss man sie mit
einer Technik an den Boden legen.
Man nimmt ein Seil
und bindet es um die Kuh herum.
Zieht man es nach hinten,
spürt sie einen Druck
und hat automatisch das Bedürfnis,
sich hinzulegen.
* Drollige Musik *
Also, damit sie sich hinlegt ...
Soll ich sie losbinden?
- Ja, man muss sie hier hochziehen.
Ich weiss zwar nicht ...
Sonst läuft sie davon.
- Ja, sie läuft davon.
Binde sie leicht an.
- Mit viel Spielraum.- Ja.
Sie muss unbedingt
auf der linken Seite liegen.
Okay. Komm!
Komm!- Voilà.
- Voilà. Doucement.
Ja, sehr gut.
Die Methode ist nicht schlecht.
Jetzt können wir sie drehen.
Es ist grenzwertig.
Der erste Schritt wäre gemacht.
Das Schwierige kommt erst noch.
Eléonore sagt jedem genau,
was er zu tun hat.
Das wird schon gehen.
Wir müssen schauen.
Jemand muss den Kopf halten. Lilly.
Ich nehme sie an den Vorderläufen,
ihr beide an den Hinterläufen
und dann drehen wir sie um.
Aufpassen,
dass sie nicht ausschlägt.
Achtung.
* Ächzen *
* Keuchen, Ächzen *
Roman, hilf ihr!
Schnell, schnell. Drücken.
Ah!
So, fertig.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Es ist wichtig zu schauen, dass
die Gebärmutter aufgedreht ist.
Erstens um sicher zu sein,
sie nicht falsch gedreht zu haben
und um zu sehen,
ob sich der Gebärmutterhals öffnet
und das Kalb raus kann.
Der Gebärmutterhals
ist noch nicht offen.
Aber sie ist nicht mehr verdreht?
- Nein, sie liegt richtig.
Sehr gut.
Wir warten mal.
Operation gelungen,
aber etwas ist noch nicht gut.
Sania muss unbedingt
wieder aufstehen.
Liegt eine Kuh zu lange,
verliert sie schnell Muskelkraft,
was schlimme Folgen haben kann.
Reiss dich ein bisschen zusammen.
Komm, Schätzchen, aufstehen.
Komm jetzt!
Komm, hopp!
Sie hat sich total gehen lassen.
- Ja, ja.
Hey, hey!
* Spannende Musik, Ächzen *
Jetzt sollte es gehen.
Wenn sie
in der richtigen Position ist.
Wenn sie auf der Seite liegt
und vier Beine in derselben Richtung
sind, kann sich nicht aufstehen.
Sania wird vom ganzen Team
angetrieben,
aber sie bleibt einfach liegen.
Thierry fährt
mit schwerem Geschütz auf.
* Spannende Musik, Motorenlärm *
Vorsicht! Vorsicht!
So geht es. Sie kann aufstehen.
- So kann sie aufstehen.
So geht es ohne grosse Anstrengung.
Wir machen so etwas nicht gern,
aber manchmal müssen wir helfen,
wenn eine Kuh nicht von sich aus
aufstehen kann.
Das Ziehen tut ihr nicht weh.
Die Füsse
sind in der richtigen Stellung,
aber Sania ist völlig erschöpft.
Ich glaube,
sie ist noch in einem Schockzustand.
Ja, sie ist ...
Sie hat noch nicht begriffen,
was passiert ist. Das ist normal.
Das ist ein Schock
und ermüdend für das Tier.
Man soll es nicht forcieren.
Wenn sie 15 Min. zum Aufrichten
braucht, lässt man ihr die Zeit.
Tatsächlich ist Sania 5 Min. später
wieder auf den Beinen.
Eléonore kann guten Gewissens gehen.
Sania wird ihr Kälbchen
nun auf die Welt bringen können.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Im Tierspital Bern treffen wir Alix,
die bereits den ersten
Notfallpatienten aufnimmt.
Es ist LOxias, ein siebenjähriger
Rhodesian Ridgeback,
der in einem Schockzustand
eingeliefert wurde.
Er hat grosse Mühe beim Atmen.
Darum machen wir sofort
einen Ultraschall.
Es fällt sofort auf,
dass mit dem Herz etwas nicht stimmt.
Da hat es auch ...
- Ja, da sieht man es.
Um die Lunge hat sich
viel Flüssigkeit angesammelt.
Schlimmer ist, dass auch
der Herzbeutel voll Flüssigkeit ist.
Das könnte
zu einem Herzstillstand führen.
Im Wartsaal ist der Nachbar der Hun-
besitzer, die in den Ferien sind.
Sie warten auf den nächsten Flug,
um schnellstmöglich zurückzukehren.
* Schluchzen *
(Weinend) Es tut mir so leid,
es ist schlimm.
Also, bis bald.
Loxias Besitzer sind völlig hilflos,
so weit weg von ihrem Hund.
Wir haben ein sehr gutes Verhältnis.
Wir kennen den Hund sehr gut.
Aber das ist schlimm.
Das sind keine
schönen Nachrichten für uns.
In der Notaufnahme organisiert Alix
die Patientenaufnahme.
Es muss schnell gehen. Alix
befürchtet einen schweren Herztumor.
Ich weiss, dass der Kardiologe
sehr rasch die Punktion machen will.
Okay, dann geben wir ihm jetzt
die Infusion.
Ja, aber er hat da Flüssigkeit.
Loxias erhält sofort eine Infusion.
In dem Zustand kann der Hund
in ein paar Stunden sterben.
Für lebensverlängernde Massnahmen
ist das Okay der Besitzer nötig.
Grüessech. Loxias?
- Ja.
Guten Tag.- Grüessech.
- Barbarino, Tierärztin.
Gehen wir ins Sprechzimmer?
- Ja, sicher.
Sie sind der Nachbar?- Genau.
- Sehr gut.
Nehmen Sie Platz.
Der Besitzer
ist via Handy erreichbar.
Das ist gut, denn wir haben
keine guten Nachrichten.
Leider besteht der Verdacht
auf eine krebsartige Erkrankung.
Es könnte eine schwere Art von Krebs
mit einer Überlebenschance
von wenigen Tagen sein.
Mhm.
Henri ist schockiert.
Er muss die traurige Nachricht
seinen Nachbarn überbringen.
Ich gebe dir die Tierärztin.
Es ist schlimmer, als wir dachten.
Danke.
- Bitte schön.
Guten Tag.
Möchten Sie, dass wir ihn
so oder so stabilisieren,
trotz der Situation,
dass Sie noch in den Ferien sind?
Im Moment ist der Zustand
sehr schlecht.
Wir versuchen, ihn zu stabilisieren,
bis Sie wieder da sind.
In so einem Fall
muss man rasch entscheiden.
Und wir müssen den Besitzer fragen,
ob der Hund
trotz der schwerwiegenden Schäden
weiterbehandelt werden soll
oder ob die Behandlung
abgebrochen werden soll.
Wir möchten ihn gerne
noch einmal sehen.
Das habe ich mir auch gedacht.
Wenn Sie einverstanden sind,
werden wir ihn gleich sedieren
und die Flüssigkeit
sofort aus dem Herzbeutel ableiten.
Das ist nicht ohne Risiko,
aber wir müssen das jetzt machen.
Wegen der vielen Flüssigkeit
funktioniert das Herz sehr schlecht.
Ja, ist gut.
- Dann machen wir das.
Einverstanden, gerne.
- Ja.
Ich leite das in die Wege.
- Tschüss.
Alix bringt Loxias zum Kardiologen.
Sie muss wissen,
ob ihre Diagnose stimmt.
Der Hund braucht dringend
eine Punktion.
Punktiert ihr hier, Alix?
- Ja, das machen wir oben.
Der Arzt ist oben.
Gut, dann geht rauf.
Ich suche noch etwas die Masse.
Aber ich möchte
nicht zu lange suchen.
Der Hund stirbt uns auf dem Tisch.
Hier, an den klassischen Stellen.
Übergang rechter Ventrikel, rechter
Vorhof sehe ich gerade nicht.
Die Ultraschalluntersuchung bestä-
tigt die Vermutung der Notaufnahme.
Der Hund hat eine Herztamponade.
Das Herz ist durch die Flüssigkeit
so zusammengedrückt,
dass es nicht mehr richtig
funktionieren kann.
Man muss die Flüssigkeit
sofort ableiten.
Es ist aber so, dass wir das, wonach
wir suchten - die Tumormasse -
nicht gesehen haben.
Also doch kein Krebs.
Es besteht noch Hoffnung.
Aber Loxias
ist noch nicht über den Berg.
Wir werden die EKG-Kontrollen
durchführen,
auf der rechten, lateralen Seite.
- Das ist gut.
Okay.
- Genau.
Alix hat einen heiklen Eingriff
vor sich.
Es ist die einzige Möglichkeit,
um Loxias zu retten.
Es ist ziemlich riskanter Eingriff,
aber wir haben keine andere Wahl.
Darum machen wir ihn.
Wir halten die Herzfunktion
immer unter Kontrolle.
Wir halten ein Mittel bereit,
das wir sofort spritzen würden,
wenn sein Herz unregelmässig
schlagen würde.
Alix sticht mit einer Nadel
durch den Brustkorb bis zum Herz.
Ein paar Millimeter daneben -
und die Folgen könnten fatal sein.
Wir können nicht lange überlegen.
Ich kenne die Technik.
Ich habe es auch schon gemacht,
aber nicht oft.
Machen wir nichts,
wird es für Loxias schlimmer,
das wollen wir nicht.
Darum geht man ohne Zögern an die
Sache: "Ich kann das und mache das."
Loxias darf sich nicht bewegen,
wenn Alix die Nadel
Richtung Herz führt.
Die Spannung steigt -
und dann ist es so weit.
Alix ist beim Herz.
Die Operation ist gelungen.
Wir haben 750 ml Blut
aus dem Herzbeutel abgeleitet.
Also 3/4 l, das ist viel.
Jetzt kann Loxias Herz
wieder besser schlagen.
Schon kommt das nächste Problem.
Sein Blut gerinnt schlecht.
Bei der kleinsten Wunde
hört es nicht auf zu bluten.
Wir tauen Blutplasma auf.
Das führen wir dann dem Hund zu.
Er hat ziemlich Probleme
mit der Blutgerinnung.
Deshalb geben wir ihm
Koagulationsfaktoren eines Spenders.
Wir haben beschlossen, die
Transfusion schneller durchzuführen,
als wir es normalerweise machen.
Sogar das kleine Löchlein,
das wir machten,
um in den Herzbeutel zu stechen,
hört nicht zu bluten auf.
Auch das ist dringend, wenn auch
etwas weniger als die Punktion.
* Spannende Musik, Stimmengewirr *
Schau da!
Du kleiner ...
* Schwungvolle Trommelmusik *
* Lockere Banjomusik *
Es ist Sonntagmorgen, aber für
Florcene ist nichts mit Ausschlafen.
Sie ist auf Pikett
und hat einen Anruf eines aufgeregten
Hundebesitzers erhalten.
Sie ist auf dem Weg in die Praxis.
Der Besitzer war total panisch.
Er sagte mir, sein Hund sei von
einem anderen Hund gebissen worden
und habe eine grosse, offene Wunde.
Hervé hat kürzlich in Sédeilles
im Kanton Waadt ein Haus gekauft.
Als er nachsah, wie der Umbau läuft,
erlebte er eine böse Überraschung.
Ich hatte meinen Hund angebunden.
Plötzlich kam der Nachbarshund,
hüpfte auf sie los
und griff sie einfach an.
(Sanft) Du bist eine Liebe,
eine Liebe.
Du bist eine Gute.
Das ging dermassen schnell. Ich
konnte gar nicht mehr eingreifen.
Hervé ist noch total aufgewühlt.
Ich habe schon etwas Angst.
Es schmerzt mich auch, ja.
Ich habe den Hund von klein auf.
Ich machte mit ihm Agility, Sport.
So gesehen ist er Teil der Familie.
Auch die Kinder hängen an ihm.
Voilà. Wie geht es? Hoi, Laica.
Also, schauen wir mal.
Ist es erst gerade passiert?
- Ja, vor Kurzem.
Der Hund war verängstigt
und sehr gestresst
und ich habe gleich gesehen,
dass er eine grosse Wunde
an der Schulter hat.
Sie hilft dir. Du machst das gut.
Können Sie den Kopf
etwas zu sich ziehen?
Ja, mhm.
Der Muskel lag frei.
Aber wie gross die Wunde war,
konnte ich aufgrund des dicken Fells
gar nicht recht anschauen.
Das muss auf jeden Fall
genäht werden.
Deshalb sediere ich ihn jetzt
zuerst einmal.- Mhm.
Jetzt, da Laica behandelt wird,
hat Hervé noch ein anderes Problem.
Wie funktioniert das,
wenn ein fremder Hund angreift?
Auf jeden Fall muss der Besitzer des
fremden Hundes die Kosten tragen.
Das ist klar.
- Ja. Mhm.
Ich fragte mich,
ob ich eine Anzeige machen soll.
Bei der Polizei.
Aber was macht man überhaupt
in einem solchen Fall?
Wenn Sie den Fall
weiterziehen wollen,
müssen Sie sich
an den kantonalen Tierarzt wenden.
Er hat schon zwei andere Hunde
angegriffen - einen im November
und einen im Februar.
Der Hund läuft ...
.. dauernd ohne Maulkorb frei herum.
Jetzt ist fertig, jetzt reicht es.
Ich sagte zu ihr,
der Hund brauche einen Maulkorb.
Sie fand,
er habe alle Tests bestanden.
Ich glaube, er muss dringend noch
einmal getestet werden.- Unbedingt.
Ein Hund, der andere Hunde beisst,
muss von einem Verhaltenstierarzt
untersucht werden,
der mit verschiedenen Tests
feststellen kann,
wie gefährlich er wirklich
für andere Hunde ist.
Der Kantonstierarzt
kann Bussen verteilen
oder einen Maulkorb vorschreiben.
In Extremfällen muss der Hund
eingeschläfert werden.
Ein Hund, der andere Hunde beisst,
kann auch ein Kind beissen,
was sehr schlimm wäre.
Das macht Hervé besonders Angst.
Er zieht bald mit
seinem kleinen Kind ins neue Haus.
Das Beruhigungsmittel wirkt,
jetzt muss genäht werden.
Zuerst muss Florence
die Wunde freilegen.
Das ist so schmerzhaft,
dass Laica trotz Spritze reagiert.
Erst dann war das ganze Ausmass
des Schadens zu sehen.
Mich überraschte
die Grösse der Wunde.
Die Wunde ist tief,
man hat den Muskel gesehen.
Zum Glück ist
kein lebenswichtiges Organ betroffen.
Der Hund war nicht in Lebensgefahr.
Das kann sich ändern.
Man muss sehr gut
und schnell nähen,
damit es später
zu keinen schlimmen Folgen kommt.
Hervé muss jetzt gehen, aber zuerst
gibt es noch ein Foto als Beweis.
Das sieht aus.
Okay, bis gleich wieder.
- Vielen Dank.
Florence kann loslegen.
Sie beginnt
mit einer Lokalanästhesie.
Um zu vermeiden, dass ich ihn
noch einmal betäuben muss,
versuche ich, mich etwas zu beeilen.
Ich habe auch noch andere Notfälle.
Jeder Stich
muss präzise gemacht sein,
damit es am Ende
eine saubere Narbe gibt.
* Angespannte Musik *
* Handyklingeln *
Die Zeit vergeht und das Nottelefon
klingelt permanent,
aber Florence ist allein.
Während des Nähens
kann sie unmöglich ans Telefon.
Es eilt.
Es dauerte etwas länger,
weil die Wunde sehr gross war.
Ich musste die Schichten
einzeln vernähen,
um die Wunde zu schliessen.
Die Operation
dauerte im Ganzen 45 Min.
So, jetzt haben wir es geschafft.
Na?
Laica erwacht langsam.
Ich schaue noch einmal, ob sie nicht
doch noch andere Verletzungen hat.
* Lockere Banjoklänge *
Laica ist wieder auf den Beinen
und ihr Verletzung scheint vergessen.
Aber das Trauma der Aggression
bleibt.
Wer weiss, wie sie das Erlebnis
psychisch verarbeitet?
Hunde sind intelligente Tiere.
Der Angriff bleibt in Erinnerung.
Künftig wird sie
anderen Hunden gegenüber
vermutlich misstrauischer sein.
Hervé kann seine Laica
wieder mit nach Hause nehmen.
So.
Du darfst wieder nach Hause gehen,
du warst sehr brav.
Sehr gut. Vielen Dank.
Merci.
- Noch einen schönen Sonntag.
* Hervé lacht. *
Adieu.- Ade.
Hervé muss noch einmal
für eine Kontrolle kommen.
Er kann sich überlegen,
ob er Anzeige erstattet oder nicht.
Zurück im Tierspital Bern. Loxias
Zustand ist immer noch kritsch.
Er wird so lange am Leben erhalten,
bis seine Besitzer
aus den Ferien zurück sind.
Alix befürchtet
einen schlimmen Krebs.
Nach der Punktion geht es dem Hund
besser, aber das heisst noch nichts.
Violaine und Cyril haben einen
18-stündigen Flug hinter sich
und sitzen jetzt voller Angst
im Wartzimmer.
Wir hatten Angst,
nicht rechtzeitig zu kommen.
Voller Schuldgefühle.
- Sicher.
Loxias dachte sicher,
wir hätten ihn alleingelassen
und würden ihn
nicht einmal besuchen.
Sie können kaum warten,
Loxias zu sehen.
Grüessech.
Gehen wir ins Sprechzimmer?
Ich muss Ihnen einige
komplizierte Dinge erklären.- Ja.
Das Problem ist,
dass wir viele Symptome haben,
die wir nur schwer miteinander
in Verbindung bringen können.
Das Einzige, das von all den Sachen
als Auslöser infrage kommen könnte,
wäre leider ein Tumor.
Leider müssen wir
sofort klarstellen,
was in dem Fall
die schlimmste Vermutung ist.
Dass wir beim Herz keinen Tumor
festgestellt haben,
heisst nicht,
dass er keinen Krebs hat.
Für Violaine ist das zu viel.
Wir machten uns Vorwürfe.
Sie müssen sich
keine Vorwürfe machen.
Das kann man nicht im Voraus sehen.
Man kann nicht
nicht in die Ferien gehen,
nur weil im nächsten Moment
etwas passieren kann.
Er war die ganze Nacht allein.
Und diese Nacht
ist er wieder ganz allein.
Ich habe mir gedacht ...
Ich möchte noch etwas Zeit
mit ihm verbringen.
Ja.
Wir müssten alle Untersuchungen
machen, um besser zu entscheiden.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik,
Stimmengewirr *
Schau, wer da ist.
Schau.
Endlich ist es so weit.
Auch wenn Loxias sehr geschwächt ist,
freut er sich,
seine Besitzer wieder zu sehen.
Wir gehen rasch raus.
Er muss schon wieder pinkeln.
Er war erst grad draussen, aber ...
Alix beschreibt
den möglichen Krankheitsverlauf.
Für Violaine ist das zu viel. Sie
macht ein paar Schritte mit Loxias.
Für mich ist Loxias
nicht einfach ein Hund.
Er ist mein Begleiter
beim Spazieren.
Ich gehe nie ohne ihn in den Garten.
Er kommt mit,
wenn ich in die obere Etage gehe.
Öffne ich einen Schrank,
schaut er sich darin um.
Er ist wie eine Person.
Er ist immer da.
Trotz der Freude, den Hund zu sehen,
schmerzt es,
weil es nicht mehr
der alte Loxias ist.
Wenn andere Hunde da sind, kann ich
ihn normalerweise kaum halten.
Er wiegt gleich viel wie ich.
Er zieht mich einfach hinterher.
Er mag Sie.
- Wir waren viel zusammen.
Er lehnt sich bei Ihnen an.
- Ja, ja. Schon.
Es war ein kurzes Wiedersehen.
Es ist wieder Zeit zum Gehen.
Auf Loxias warten
weitere Untersuchungen.
Ich rufe Sie auf jeden Fall an.
Ich sage Ihnen, ob er gefressen hat
und gebe Ihnen weitere Infos.
Also, gehen wir.
Ah, edel, sogar mit einem Cape.
Eh, Kleiner, bleib brav.
Vielen Dank.
- Gern geschehen.
Ich rufe sofort an.- Merci, adieu.
- So, gehen wir.
Komm, du kannst wieder liegen.
Es ist für Loxias nicht einfach,
sich zu trennen.
Also.
Adieu.
Heute Morgen dachten wir,
dass er beruhigt ist,
wenn er uns sieht
und dass er sich gehen lassen kann.
Als ich ihn mit der Tierärztin
gesehen habe,
habe ich das Gefühl,
dass er sich wohlfühlt.
Ja, und er lehnt sich an.
Er lehnt sich an sie, wie zu Hause.
- Ja.
Deshalb denke ich, dass es
vielleicht noch Hoffnung gibt.
Auch wenn es noch so schwierig ist,
Violaine und Cyril sind erleichtert.
Der Hund ist in guten Händen.
Alix hat endlich Feierabend.
Morgen ist ein langer Tag
und auf Loxias wartet
eine Reihe von Untersuchungen.
In Estavayer-le-Lac
treffen wir Eléonore.
Sie macht sich gleich auf den Weg.
Ihr Auto ist eine fahrende Apotheke.
Man muss auf alles gefasst sein.
Endlich hat sie alles. Es fehlt
nur noch Australie, ihr Hündchen.
Nein, nein, nein. Australie, komm!
Gehen wir spazieren?
Boah!
Heute fährt Eléonore zu Sylvie.
Sylvie ist eine spezielle Bäuerin,
die einen Bio-Hof führt.
und den Traktor gegen Zugpferde
ausgetauscht hat.
Die Comtois
sind eine besondere Rasse
und Sylvies grosse Leidenschaft.
Mit diesen Zugpferden
kann sie ihre Felder auf eine
umweltfreundliche Art bearbeiten.
Sie hat zehn Comtois-Pferde,
die sie täglich umsorgt und pflegt.
Einmal im Jahr kommt Eléonore
wegen der Impfung gegen Tetanus
und Pferdegrippe.
* Lockere Gitarrenmusik *
Grüessech.
- Bonjour.
Alles okay?- Danke, und Ihnen?
- Mir auch, merci.
Heute impfen wir drei Pferde.
- Jawohl.
Da haben wir Hercule und Horace.
- Ja. Die beiden sind kastriert.
Eléonore kommt regelmässig vorbei,
um zu sehen, wie es den Pferden geht.
Das ist Hercule. Den kenne ich.
Das ist mein Liebling.
Salut.
Voilà, super.
Schon fertig.
- Gut gemacht.
Und jetzt Horace.
Seit er kastriert ist, lässt er sich
nicht mehr gerne behandeln.
Er ist beleidigt.
- Ah, ja.
Er denkt,
wir würden ihm wieder etwas machen.
Sylvie versucht es
mit feinschmeckenden Pferdeleckerli,
die eigentlich immer funktionieren.
Aber Horace
lässt sich nicht reinlegen.
Er hat keine guten Erinnerungen
an Eléonore.
* Rasante Musik, Stimmengewirr *
Oh, ui!
Hallo, Horace.
Nette Worte reichen nicht,
um ihn zu besänftigen.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh!
Voilà. Fertig.
Ich wollte Ihnen noch etwas zeigen.
- Das kleine Loch.
Da, sehen Sie.
Wenn Eléonore schon mal da ist,
fragt Sylvie noch
ein paar weitere Dinge.
Es ist zurückgegangen.
Es ist nicht schlimm,
aber es kommt wieder.
Ein paar gute Ratschläge,
dann muss Eléonore weiter.
Du bist doch nicht so nachtragend.
Ich rufe in einem Monat an.
- Kein Problem.
Einen schönen Tag. Adieu.
- Adieu.
Eléonore muss gehen,
sie hat heute weitere Besuche vor.
Wir sind wieder bei Laica.
Als sie mit ihrem Herrchen auf
der Baustelle des neuen Hauses war,
wurde sie von einem anderen Hund
angegriffen und verletzt.
Dieses Mal kommt der Hund
mit Chantal und Erwan,
die sich wegen der Verletzung
grosse Sorgen machen.
Ganz ruhig, ganz ruhig.
* Lachen *
Die Kinder
hatten schon viele Fragen.
Wo der andere Hund sei,
ob es Laica besser gehen würde
und ob sie wieder
gesund werden würde.
Es gibt viele Fragen.
Kann sie wieder raus?
Die Wunde ist entzündet.
Florence und ihre Assistentin
schauen sich die Sache genau an.
Der Plastik störte etwas.
Dem Hund geht es gut.
Die Halskrause
hat ihn etwas gestört.
Es braucht sie, damit er sich nicht
kratzt oder die Fäden rauszieht.
Also, ja. Da oben hält es noch gut.
Hat sie an der Wunde geschleckt?
Ja. Und v.a.
kratzt sie sich ständig.
Sie zog auch die Fäden raus.
Wir hatten Angst
vor einer Infektion.
Der Geruch war sehr stark
und relativ unangenehm.
Es sieht nicht schön aus.
Laica zog die Fäden raus, darum hat
sich die Wunde wieder geöffnet.
Die Wunde war eindeutig unsauber.
Deshalb hat es unter dem Einstich
eine leichte Entzündung gegeben.
Es kann eine Infektion geben.
Die Haut könnte absterben.
Dann könnte man die Wunde
nicht mehr richtig schliessen.
Es hat eine leichte
bakterielle Infektion gegeben.
Aber damit haben wir gerechnet,
weil es doch ein Hundebiss war.
Erwan schaut genau zu,
wie Florence die Wunde desinfiziert.
Ich bin extra mitgekommen,
weil ich Tierarzt werden möchte.
Oh, du möchtest Tierarzt werden?
- Ja.- Super.
Die werden nämlich gebraucht.
* Florence lacht. *
Ruhig, ruhig, Laica.
Es tut dem Hund zu sehr weh.
Florence muss es anders machen.
Wir müssen sie noch einmal sedieren.
Es dauert nicht lange,
aber es tut weh,
wenn man die Klammer
ins Gewebe drückt.
Das machen wir also besser
unter Narkose. Schon gut, ja, ja.
Halten Sie sie gut.
- Ja.
V.a. den Kopf.
Chantal erlebt den Eingriff
aus nächster Nähe
Ganz wohl ist ihr dabei nicht.
Sie und ihr Mann haben beschlossen,
den Nachbarshund nicht anzuzeigen,
auch wenn er Laica gebissen hat.
Das sind unsere neuen Nachbarn.
Wir reden direkt mit ihnen,
anstatt sofort Probleme zu haben.
Wir sind zusammengesessen
und haben geredet.
Wir haben uns geeinigt,
keine Anzeige zu machen,
wenn der Hund
nicht mehr frei herumläuft.
Trotzdem hat Chantal Mühe,
ihre neuen Nachbarn zu verstehen.
Wäre es unser Hund,
der schon andere Hunde angreift,
hätten wir ihn vermutlich getötet
und einen anderen gekauft
und ihn nicht behalten.
Schliesslich haben wir Kinder.
Greift er andere Hunde an,
kann er auch Kinder angreifen.
Darum hätten wir ihn ...
Aber wir sind ja
nicht unsere Nachbarn,
darum kann ich nichts sagen.
So, jetzt sieht es
schon viel besser aus.
Der Eingriff ist fertig
und Chantal kann aufatmen.
Der zukünftige Tierarzt Erwan
diskutiert mit Florence
über die Medikamente,
die Laica nehmen muss.
Das habt ihr ihr fünf Tage gegeben?
Sie nimmt es nicht.
- Sie mag es nicht?
Sie ist wählerisch,
denn es ist gut für sie.
Sie muss es für drei Tage nehmen,
ab Morgen früh. Ist das gut?
Nimmst du das?
Laica darf wieder nach Hause.
Halt! Langsam.
Sch ...
Die Narkose wirkt immer noch.
Ich glaube, wir müssen sie
zum Auto tragen.- Tragen? Ja.
Halten Sie sie vorne?
- Jawohl.
* Drollige Musik *
Achtung, wegen dem anderen Hund.
- Ui, den habe ich vergessen.
Am Eingang knurrt Laica einen Hund
an, der vor der Türe steht.
Diese Haltung
gefällt Chantal gar nicht.
Wir möchten nicht,
dass unser Hund aggressiv wird.
Wir passen gut auf.
Sobald es ihr besser geht
und die Narbe verheilt ist,
machen wir einen Kurs, damit sie
kein anderes Verhalten annimmt.
Dank speziellen Sozialisierungskursen
wird Laica wieder gesund
und verliert die Angst
vor anderen anderen Hunden.
* Lockere Musik *
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Loxias ist immer noch
im Tierspital Bern.
Alix hat ihm gestern Flüssigkeit
aus dem Herzbeutel abgesogen
und ihm so das Leben gerettet.
Ja, ja. Schon gut.
Das Team vom Tierspital
vermutet Krebs,
aber die Diagnose ist unklar.
Um sicher zu sein,
braucht es weitere Untersuchungen.
* Piepsen *
Die Leute brauchen eine Antwort.
Bei all den Symptomen
möchten sie wissen,
ob der Hund noch normal
bei ihnen leben kann
und wieder so fit wie früher wird.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Das gibt einen langen Tag
für Loxias und Alix.
Ups.
Keine Angst, es ist alles gut.
Als Erstes
noch einmal ein Ultraschall.
Komm, das kennst du schon.
Wir tun dir nicht weh.
* Lockere Musik *
... nicht eindeutig.
Und nun eine Radiografie der Lunge.
Es ist nicht einfach,
Loxias auf den Rücken zu legen.
Resultat?
Ich sehe nichts Spezielles.
Auch da - nichts Neues.
Und zum Schluss zum Herzspezialisten.
Alix, ich sehe
wirklich weiterhin nichts.
Nichts, das eindeutig wäre.
Nein, nein.
Nach all den Untersuchungen
keine Spur eines Tumors.
Keine klare Diagnose,
die man den Besitzern vorlegen kann.
Alix selbst ist im Ungewissen.
Es macht mich traurig.
Ich hätte ihnen gern
eine klare Antwort gegeben.
Aber leider liefern die Resultate
keine schlüssige Erklärung.
Violaine und Cyril holen Loxias ab.
Alix muss ihnen sagen,
wie es aussieht.
Grüessch. Das ist ja purer Luxus.
Hallo, wie geht's?
- Es geht, danke.
Ich würde Ihnen gern zu 100 % sagen,
dass wir sicher wissen, was es ist.
Leider können wir das
nach wie vor immer noch nicht.
Wir haben einen Verdacht
und es bleibt ein Verdacht,
auch wenn die Chance, dass es
nicht das ist, bei 2 % liegt.
Wir finden keine klare Antwort,
aber das liegt nicht am Hund.
Wir haben ihn durchlöchert
und wissen nicht, was ihm fehlt.
Wir sind froh, dass er so lieb ist.
Da ist nicht selbstverständlich.
Geniess es!
Keines der lebenswichtigen Organe
ist betroffen.
Die unerklärlichen Herzprobleme
könnten jederzeit wieder kommen.
Violaine und Cyril
nehmen Loxias wieder mit.
Ohne Behandlung und ohne Gewissheit.
Wir gehen jetzt mal weiter
und versuchen,
uns an den Gedanken zu gewöhnen,
dass er von uns gehen könnte.
Es wird nicht ewig gehen, darum
schauen wir einfach mal vorwärts.
Nach ein paar Tagen können wir es
sicher besser akzeptieren.
Jetzt geniessen wir mal den Moment.
Wir nehmen es, wie es kommt.
Tag für Tag.
* Niederprasselnder Regen *
Loxias lebt ab jetzt im Ungewissen.
Für Violaine und Cyril ist jeder
Augenblick mit ihm noch kostbarer.
Wir sind in der Nähe von Payerne.
Maguy führte 30 Jahre lang
ein Restaurant.
Jetzt lebt sie mit ihren Tieren
auf dem Land.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Ich sagte immer, ich würde Pferde
kaufen, wenn ich pensioniert bin.
Und dann habe ich mich
in die Geisslein verliebt.
Sie sind mir ans Herz gewachsen.
Trotz aller Liebe kennt sie sich
noch nicht gut mit ihnen aus.
Sie hat sie seit sechs Wochen.
Sie wird unsicher,
wenn etwas nicht stimmt.
Ich mache mir Sorgen um Paloma.
Darum rief ich die Tierärztin an.
Ich weiss nicht,
warum sie einen dicken Bauch hat.
Vielleicht ist sie trächtig, aber es
könnte auch eine Infektion sein.
Maguy hat zwar keinen Geissbock,
aber Paloma könnte bei ihrem vorher-
igen Besitzer gedeckt worden sein.
Um das abzuklären,
kommt Florence vorbei.
Sie bringt
ihren neuen Ultraschallapparat mit.
Das Gerät stelle ich hierhin.
Sie sieht sofort,
um welches Geisslein es geht.
Ist es dieses? Mit dem dicken Bauch?
Es ist kugelrund. Sehen Sie?
Sie hat einen dicken Bauch.
Im Vergleich zu den anderen ...
- Die andere hat auch ein Bäuchlein.
Wir können beide untersuchen.
Nur der Ultraschall
kann da Gewissheit verschaffen.
Keine Angst, ich tu dir nicht weh.
Die Untersuchung macht nicht weh,
genauso wie beim Menschen.
* Meckern *
Das Gel ist kalt, aber so ein Theater
ist nun übertrieben.
* Schleppende Musik,
wiederholtes Meckern *
Nun stimmt auch noch Cerise mit ein.
* Aufgeregtes Meckern *
Hör auf mit dem Geschrei.
- Hört ihr auf?
Das Bild ist nicht gut.
Das Gerät ist neu und Florence
kennt sich noch nicht gut damit aus.
Das macht die Sache nicht einfacher.
Zuerst hatte ich
ein sehr schlechtes Bild.
Ich konnte die Gebärmutter
nicht richtig erfassen.
Anstatt herumzuprobieren,
ruft Florence ihre Chefin an.
Du hast mir letzthin gesagt,
ich müsse Hundebauch einstellen.
Ah, also in der Mitte ...
Ah, rechts, genau. Depth.
Ich habe es gesehen, ja.
Ja, ja. Ist gut.
Die technischen Probleme
wären gelöst.
Jetzt kann Florence etwas sehen.
Das dort ist es.
Also ...
Ich sehe keine Anzeichen
einer Schwangerschaft.
Alle sind erstaunt,
dass Paloma kein Geisslein erwartet.
* Rhythmische Bassklänge *
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Ich war mir ziemlich sicher,
dass sie trächtig ist.
Da ist nichts.
Es gibt noch eine andere Erklärung
für ihren dicken Bauch.
Ziegen sind sehr anhängliche Tiere.
Man verwöhnt sie sehr gern.
Man gibt ihnen Essensreste,
trockenes Brot, Kraftfutter, Gras.
Also eigentlich viel zu viel.
Darum können Ziegen
rasch einmal dick werden.
* Lockere Banjomusik *
So, komm!
Weil sie ohnehin da ist,
untersucht Florence auch noch Cerise.
* Meckern *
Siehe da!
Sie ist trächtig.
- Nein.
Maguy ist sprachlos
und glaubt es kaum.
Unten ist die Wirbelsäule.
Die Füsse schauen nach oben.
Und in der Mitte
sieht man das Herz schlagen.
* Meckern *
D.h., seine Böcke waren
offensichtlich nicht kastriert.
Oder es war der heilige Geist.
* Meckern *
Der vorherige Besitzer sagte ihr
zwar, die Ziege sei nicht trächtig.
Aber es hatte einen Bock und man
weiss nicht immer, was die machen.
Ich dachte, die andere Ziege
sei trächtig, aber nicht Cerise.
Da sieht man es wirklich gut.
- Zum Glück untersuchten Sie sie.
Man sah sogar das Herz schlagen.
So weiss man auch,
dass das Geisslein lebt.
Und das ist auch wunderschön.
Was ich nicht sagen kann, ist,
ob es ...
Wie viel tragen sie normalerweise?
- Eins oder zwei.
Bald hat Maguy noch
ein weiteres Geisslein im Stall.
Trächtig.
- Rein mit dir.
Gut.
Ich weiss nicht - ist es
eine gute oder schlechte Nachricht?
Schlecht ist sie sicher nicht.
Wir haben genügend Platz.
Auf Wiedersehen.
- Merci. Adieu.
Florence arbeitet seit zwei Jahren
in Payerne.
Es gefällt ihr auf dem Land.
Das ist gut.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, das
aufzugeben und im Büro zu arbeiten.
Ich bin gern draussen
bei den Tieren.
* Lockere Musik *
In sechs Monaten beendet Alix ihre
Ausbildung in der Berner Notaufnahme.
Ich brauche einen Beruf, bei dem ich
nicht weiss, was auf mich zukommt.
Das gefällt mir.
Sie bildet sich weiter
als Notfalltierärztin.
Dazu geht sie nach Alfort
in der Nähe von Paris.
Eléonore, nach drei Jahren Erfahrung,
hat immer noch
ein grosses Herz für Tiere.
Ich möchte eines Tages meine eigene
Praxis eröffnen: Klinik Eléonore.
Neben der Praxis gibt es ein Heim
für Tiere, die niemand mehr will
oder ins Schlachthaus kommen.
* Instrumental: "Beards & Bells"
von Brain Lovechild & Charles Casey *